[Music]
hello
welcome everyone we're so excited that
you could join us today
for our partners and families panel it's
thrilling to have you all here and i
thank you so much for making some time
to be with us today
so first up just to ground us a little
bit and what's going to happen next
we are going to have about 55 minutes
together today
and while i will be on hand to hopefully
answer some
basic tactical or logistical questions
about
uh applying and navigating the stanford
mba experience
this time is really meant to be spent
with our students our alumni
and their partners to really understand
and get a deeper
uh appreciation for the stanford gsb
experience from their perspective
so i'll kick things off with a few
questions but i really invite all of you
to utilize this q a box this evening
and feel free to ask any questions that
are on your mind
today as it will be helpful for you
all right so a few things before we get
started
because this is a little different than
maybe some of our traditional sessions
where we're talking just strictly about
some of the academic experiences
this is a huge commitment that you're
thinking about making and we know this
isn't a decision you're making on your
own
uh others are involved in this
decision-making process with you
and so it's important to understand that
here at stanford there are a number of
resources and
and support systems in place for not
only our students but for the members of
their families as well
and so we do actually have on campus and
stanford
affiliated housing that you and your
partners and families can be moving into
on campus which is pretty great
uh for those of you who may be moving
here from another
geographic location and your partner is
thinking about
conducting their own job search we do
actually have some career
support for them there are also support
systems in terms of student
organizations and and family clubs
and other activities that partners and
families can be involved in during their
time here
uh something else just mentioning at a
high level today for all of you
uh our financial aid is need-based and
if you are coming with a spouse or a
family member uh
or or kids all of that is factored into
the the need-based financial aid process
in addition to that this was actually
some new information for me as i
prepared for this session
there's actually some additional funds
and grants available
for families here at stanford so if you
have more questions about that i can try
to pop some of those links into the
chats
during our discussion today all right so
with that
i just wanted to do a very high level
because i'm going to ask all of our
panelists to
share a little bit about their living
situation on campus
because i think it will help acclimate
all of us they're
we're actually very fortunate at
stanford there are a number of on-campus
graduate housing
options for our students so for single
students for couples
and for families we have quite a number
of options both within the stanford
campus and what they refer to as
off-campus subsidized housing which is a
lot of housing that might be just one or
two miles or
in some cases directly across the street
from stanford's campus right here in
palo alto california
so just wanted to let you know that as
you're thinking about making this big
move
there are lots of options in terms of
where you might find yourself living in
the future
so with that i'm going to turn things
over to our panel
i'm gonna have our little uh intro slide
here up for just a minute and then i'm
gonna actually open things up so you can
see our whole panel here today
but what i'd like to do first is just do
a quick round
for our panel if you could share who you
are where you're dialing in from today
yourself
and if you lived off campus on campus
a little bit about that i'm sure we'll
get some more questions later
so i'm going to bounce around the screen
here and i think we'll kick things off
with
parker welcome thanks for being here
yeah i know thanks so much for having us
so i'm here with lacey
and then lacey's got our little guy uh
nate so bonus panelist today
so i'm calling in we're both calling him
from salt lake city utah
um i'm still at work places at home
still um
and let's see what was oh we lived in
escondido village
excellent that was the family housing
with the
they're different there's different
escalator village housing but we lived
in the family housing
excellent and lacey would you like to
introduce yourself
yeah so i i came with parker to the gsb
um we came from texas and at the time we
had three children
we had our fourth child wall in school
um
and so the family housing and the
the family life is where i have a lot of
expertise it's down first if you have
questions
around that i am willing and happy to
answer wonderful thanks so much
uh amanda let's turn things over to you
next
hi yes i'm amanda i am a
incoming second year mba from australia
um
uh as you can see i come from education
consulting but used my time at stanford
to pivot into real estate urban
environment work and so i'm currently
interning with a real estate developer
um
over the summer and i'm in portugal um
which is why it looks like it's night
time here
um tori is my partner i'll let her
introduce herself
excellent and amanda where were you
living on campus during year one oh
sorry um
i have lived actually in both jmac and
schwab um the rivalry between them
is false and means nothing but if you
want to get competitive go ahead
thanks uh let's turn things over to tori
hi i'm tori um i moved to schwab to live
with amanda from australia
um and did the whole
getting a visa to work in the us job
search
um to get across so if you have any
questions about that
uh more than happy to chat excellent
thanks
and let's turn things over to natalia
and eric
hi i'm natalia we're calling it from new
york i was
class of 2020 and i lived in schwab my
first year
and i came from finance now
i'm starting my own company and also am
now an so because eric just started at
the gsb so we're exactly two years apart
yeah we uh we did not time that out too
well
but as natalia mentioned my name's eric
i am one of amanda's classmates arising
a second year at the business school
uh nathalie and i live together in
schwab this past year which was which
was a great experience
and i come from a background in
healthcare and government and interning
and consulting for
the summer looking forward to chatting
with y'all awesome
well with that i'm going to stop sharing
the screen so i can pull everybody up
and hopefully you can see
all of us here now as a full panel uh i
am going to kick things off with a
couple of questions for the group
uh and i see we've got one in the q a
box so far but
get those questions coming in and we're
going to do our best to answer as many
as possible in the next 45 minutes or so
but to kick things off uh i'll open this
up to
anyone who's interested maybe we'll try
to hear from from two folks at a time
and we'll work on getting through as
much as possible
so first up what were some of the
important considerations that you had in
mind when preparing
for graduate school especially knowing
that you were going to be making this
decision
not just as an individual but a decision
that would affect
others as well who wants to to tackle
this one first
i'm happy to so
uh i think you know we went to school
went to grad school um at a time where
we already had three kids as lacy
mentioned so i think
pertinent to this this panel discussion
for me it was for me is really important
that it wasn't just a great learning
and development and life experience for
me personally but also that it was
really great for
for lacey and for our kids and so i
think one thing that really helped us
was seeing escondido village and
for those that are not familiar it's
this sort of like grouping of townhomes
and it's a place where you can live if
you have
children and so um you know a lot of the
gsb
does run on the single person's schedule
um but because we were in this
escondido village area we were able to
build kind of our own community of other
families and other parents
and that was an incredible opportunity
so i think
um yeah just thinking about who are the
other people that i love like
that i care about in my life and how
will this experience affect them and
making sure that they will have an
incredible life experience as well
at the same time
thanks parker uh does anyone else want
to to chime in in terms of anything else
that
was of consideration for you when you
were making this decision
i think um making sure that
going in there is buy-in from both
people and term
an expectation setting around what type
of cadence you have to have
in order to keep in touch and make sure
depending we did long distance a part of
it we want we weren't always in person
and so
just making sure that there was a sense
of um
rhythm and cadence when we were thinking
about how is this going to work like
what does this actually look like
if i do make the decision to go to
school
great thank you so i see
tori oh amanda go ahead i'm
sorry if you go ahead if you tori was
actually answering a question in the q a
box so i was just saying oh good okay
so we obviously moved internationally um
which
is a big a big deal and internationally
during a pandemic
which also was not particularly easy so
when you say making sure that everybody
is committed
we had to have some very um very honest
and very frank conversations early to
say not only
are we going to try this graduate school
thing but also
try the graduate school thing tori
needed to find a way to work in the
united states which
um which does come with its own
challenges and i'm sure for those i see
lots of internationals so for those
with their sos who are looking to work
in the us that's
that's a whole tricky process as well
which needs to get started early
um and then i think making sure
and we can talk about this more but
making sure that your so has their
life too whether it is part of a
community of
partners on campus or families on campus
or has connection
as well as just an so all right
quick uh point of clarification for
everyone throughout our conversation
today you may hear
our panel refer to things as so
and or partners so uh sort of officially
we try to use the
the term partners here on campus but so
is just part of the vernacular here at
stanford graduate school of business or
the gsb
as you might hear it referred to so if
you ever have any questions about any
abbreviations we may be using uh feel
free to
pop those in the chat questions uh
speaking of questions
i know tori was answering in the chat
but i think this is actually a great one
for everyone to hear as well
what are some types of events or
activities that the essos or partners
can get involved with
on campus so for those of you who have
been partners
on campus do you want to share a little
bit about some of the different things
that you've been able to get involved
with during your time here
yeah happy too um i think estos can
be involved in a lot
basically anything socially um i ended
up you know
spending a lot of time around campus
getting to know other people and going
for some of the social events and on
trips with others
all of that is very much open season for
sos
in addition there are definitely some
professional events particularly the
student organized ones that essos
are often welcome to join um such as
the student conferences and some
of the student organized sessions for um
i went i went to i worked in healthcare
so i went to a session meeting
uh someone from gosh i can't remember
but it was a large us health insurer
that was organized by
one of the students obviously not class
but to be fair
you know that's that's okay
uh yeah you can really get involved in
in quite a lot if you're in so
and motivated to involve yourself um in
student life
i'll answer this one also um and i do
apologize i started reading so i might
duplicate a little bit of what tori said
but um there is a lot of involvement you
can do obviously you can't attend
classes because
you haven't been admitted to the program
but if your partner
or whatever is presenting or
particularly enjoy the class
they can always ask if you can come i
think i attended
every class that was parker's favorite i
went at least once
um there's a view from the top where you
have
you know incredible people have
accomplished a lot of things that come
speaking you can participate in all of
that
you can't go on trips i saw a question
about trips
you can't go on trips that are organized
by the school but there are lots of
trips that are organized
by students and that's free game um so
the involvement is you get in what you
what whatever you want you can have that
experience so
um there are also groups that you can
attend so if you're a
partner when i was there it was called
biz partners i don't know if it's still
called that i still call that okay
and also biz kids if you have children
um which is a great community and a
great network
um just to be able to you know find
where you belong some people have a hard
time adjusting to
being at the gsb when you are not a
student and i recommend just
holding on and finding your people and
going with it and creating your own
experience
and i'm going to jump in because there
was one thing that lacy didn't mention
but one of the ways we got to know each
other during her time at the gsb was
uh significant others and partners are
actually able to join some of our
administrative
uh committees on campus so lacey
actually worked with us
in planning our admitted student weekend
uh and so
that's actually an opportunity that's
open to partners
and significant others if you're
interested in actually helping to shape
some of the activities that we plan on
campus for the new students joining us
and their families
christine
all right looks like the next question
may also be for parker and lacy because
i'm seeing a bunch in the q a box
about balancing family and the very
challenging
rigorous mba academic uh coursework
course load
so parker as the student uh can you tell
us a little bit about
how you manage your prioritization and
balancing all of that
uh and lacie maybe any other advice you
had as well for the partner who was
uh married to a very busy mba student
yeah so i think one of the driving
forces of nature that sort of runs
underneath
everything um in grad school is fomo
so like the fear of missing out and so
i think coming in to the program knowing
that we have
a family and that my schedule typically
runs very different from
somebody that maybe doesn't have a
family there's definitely a lot of fear
of missing out on social
activities and other things because of
course one of the main reasons that you
do
an mba is for developing those
relationships and
the network and having those experiences
so i think
um i think the discipline that that was
sort of naturally required was just
prioritization and really being
thoughtful about
do i really need to go to a social event
every single night of the week
maybe some weeks but probably not most
weeks
and so i think just being super
thoughtful about what do i actually care
about participating in
and i will say that uh you know we were
really happy with our social
experience at the gsb not just
connecting with other
families but also connecting with all
kinds of different students
single married with kids without kids
etc etc
and i do think one one thing that did
help us is realizing
that uh when you have kids sometimes
students that don't have kids assume
that you're too busy or maybe like you
don't
want to do something socially and so we
took
we took it on ourselves a little bit
more to try to reach out and invite
people over for dinner just so they knew
hey
yes we have a family but we're not so
busy with our family that we don't want
to have
you know that relationship with with you
so
we would do it again in a heartbeat and
you know our older kids have
friends that they've made that i think
will be lifetime friends that met out
out on the playground at escondido
village so um
so yeah we would do again in a heartbeat
um
so to figure back on what parker said i
think that the biggest thing was was
scheduling because there's going to be a
lot of things that your
students could do that they won't do as
parents because
um because you just can't be gone every
single night until the wee hours of the
morning like a single student might be
able to um
not say he didn't go to vegas so for one
night being or whatever there's still
opportunity to enjoy that part too
um but you just have to make choices and
and for us it was like parker said
inviting people to our
house where they could be where our kids
were you know felt safe
and liked meeting different people or
going to campus to
meet parker for lunch and so you see all
the students and you you
make those connections still but in a
way that's more family friendly and
more suited for the stage of life that
you might be in
thanks lacey speaking of stages of life
and where you might be in i would love
to turn things over to
uh natalia and eric because you have a
unique perspective because you have both
been students at the gsb
and partners at the gsb so uh wondering
if you can kind of shed some insights
there in terms of some things that might
be helpful for folks to consider
um from either perspective whether
they're students coming with their
partners or what that partner experience
might be like now that you've seen it
from both perspectives
yeah i would say that if possible if
your partner is planning to apply to
school definitely do the exact same
thing we did because then
the second person to go really has a leg
up because they have the expert
uh in the room and in all social meetups
which is great
um no i think it's a great question
question christine and there's probably
a lot of different ways we could go with
it
um i think the first and it's really
important as actually natalia's already
mentioned is
deciding um whether or not you're going
to be in the same place
and that might be out of the question
for a lot of the families on the line
but for us it was
an important conversation of would you
know i moved to san francisco
uh or the bay area um and and kind of
live either in person
or even just like that middle distance
between san francisco and
and uh living on campus and that's
ultimately what we did
um when she was a student um was i was
living in in san francisco
and she was living down in the bay and
um we made it work
um and it kind of kept a little bit of a
distance and cadence
in things um so i think that's a really
important question to consider is
kind of optimizing for that work life
balance and
um if your partner is interested in
investing more in the community and kind
of having
um kind of a more individual exposure to
their class and really getting some of
those opportunities that
um you know might not be something that
a working person is keen to
to do then that's an important
conversation to have in setting those
boundaries and expectations and i think
for us um both of us found a lot of
happiness
in having one-on-one relationships with
the other person's class
so for example i wasn't relying on my
happiness
and my schedule just through eric like i
feel like i had individual relationships
with his classmates and
that and of itself i think makes it a
lot easier
and much more fruitful for the partner
and also for the student because then
there's not
there's sort of like an independence and
it's not fully
kind of like a codependence as you're
kind of building your own life on campus
yeah thank you both amanda tori i'd love
to hear
because i know you faced similar choices
you know relocating from an
international location
figuring out long distance and moving on
campus can you talk to the group a
little bit about how you navigated that
process
i'm happy to go first um
gosh it was uh an interesting experience
i mean we
we started doing um long distance
which was really necessary given the
covert pandemic
it wasn't it wasn't so much out of
choices necessity
um and uh
that was we we made that work for us um
we sorted out some rhythms obviously we
had a
very significant time difference between
the two of us um i was in
melbourne and amanda was in palo alto
um but we made it work by you know
putting in time
because some couples may be thinking
about doing long distance or may have to
do long distance because of visa reasons
for quite a while
um we put time in each other's calendars
um every week that was reserved for us
to hang out with each other
life can be really busy on campus at
stanford and it's all so exciting
and new um that it it can be
hard to make time for um for other
things in your life so we made sure to
have some dedicated time where um
where amanda wasn't allowed to go and do
something else
no i'm joking um uh so we made that work
for us we did long distance for
um gosh five months i think um
and then uh moving on
campus um we spent some time
just making sure that we got settled in
and amanda was really proactive about
making sure that i felt welcomed and
included introduced
me to a lot of her friends and um
i found it really i found it quite easy
to settle into the community actually
which was
um which was great everyone um was super
welcoming uh
and yeah we had a great time living in
trump
well and this is actually a great segue
to ask amanda you mentioned living in j
mac and schwab so i am going to go out
and make a little bit of an assumption
that you might have started at jmac and
then
when you were able to move in together
you were able to make the move to the
couple's housing in schwab
so for others who may be dialing in who
may be facing a similar situation where
they might have to start long distance
but there may be an opportunity for
their partner to join
later can you talk a little bit about
how you navigated that process
uh yes um
[Music]
oh no oh i think i'm amanda sorry
you're back start again sorry my
internet connection's not great so i
apologize
um plan early so uh we knew that toyota
was going to arrive
sort of at the start of the winter
quarter-ish
we communicated oh have i gone off again
yeah i'm just gonna let torrey
i'm i will try and interpret what um
what amanda was um
from what i recall um yes we definitely
planned early
um amanda knew when i was going to
arrive so she was in contact with
um the gsb residences
and arthelene co about
what rooms might be available
particularly as the
terms changed over because there is some
shift in and out of people
um in schwab and jmac um
i hope i'm reading it alone correctly
it's a long distance to read
um all right it's doing perfectly
so um we actually found a room in schwab
sometimes i mean the couple rooms are
very popular i
i wouldn't say that they're you know
difficult to get when moving in
um but uh because they are
kind of you know a modification of two
single rooms
so they can kind of make couple rooms
happen but um they need a bit of warning
to make that happen
so um yeah we just worked early with the
gsb residences and they were able to
to have a couple's room available for us
when we moved in which was great
yeah also um we did consider other
options
so we do know lots of lots of partners
who um like include jewel either
no amanda maybe if you head off video we
might still be able to
catch your audio we can give that a try
all right we may have to come back to
amanda there um
just engaged by a chat it's okay
fantastic please do
i'm going to switch gears a little bit
now thank you all for your contacts
there i think that's very helpful um
because i know housing can
can be something that can make folks
anxious because there are so many
options
um but for our couples as i mentioned in
addition to to the
schwab couples housing uh couples may
also live at escondido village
or in munger so lots of options on
campus
um something else that's come up now a
couple of times in q and a
are the options for day care or child
care on campus
so parker lacey i'm wondering if that's
something that you utilize
and might be able to speak to or if you
know any classmates that did
i don't want to rush around too much
looking for the links
on this site but i can try if either of
you can maybe get us started in that
conversation
so i did just post the link i think it
would go through to the web
to the daycares and we did not use the
daycare on campus but we had lots of
friends who did
um i will say that when you're moving to
campus there was it was probably about
50 50 of
of parents that were both working or
parents
who maybe were working before and then
decided not to just during that
experience or parents who were just stay
at home parents because that's the
decision that they had made
and so there's not really a right or a
wrong way
to do that um but the
child care options offered at stanford
are actually
really really great um i've had some
friends claim but they're the best
teachers
you know you can find anywhere in the
country which might be the truth um
in particular madera grove and ccsc
um have had a lot of
um positive feedback at least while we
were there which was two years ago but
i imagine not too much has changed in
that time and specifically
one friend who um her two young
daughters were there
during all the coveted stuff and just
really impressed with the ways that they
handled all of that for young children
because that's i mean their world was
shake
was you know disrupted too um that being
said
the wait lists can be quite long um so
if that is something that you are
interested in
it's a good idea to reach out early and
often um
and then also during covert a lot of
people have been using nanny shares
and that happened while we were there
too but you just get you know your
escondido neighbors
right next door or whatever and you can
just hire somebody together
um and that was a good solution for a
lot of people
um somebody asked about the what how the
schools are handling
covid now and we we left before
covet hit we graduated 2019 um
but um i have heard that kindergartners
and first graders and second graders
were back in person at the end of last
year so if you have children older than
that let me know but i think at least
those kids are back in person
and planning to start again in the fall
thanks lacey and i did my best to try to
add the the link there in the
chat which i think is open to everyone
uh this next question is from rashmi and
i think i'm going to direct this to
eric because eric you mentioned that
when you were the partner
uh you were actually living off campus
for
during that experience living up in san
francisco so rashmi has a partner who
will need to commute
in the south bay and wondering if um you
can maybe speak to the pros and cons of
living off campus versus living on
campus and i think now you're in a
position where you've seen it both ways
oh yes yeah i can definitely uh
definitely share a few thoughts on that
so um so yeah as i mentioned i was
living in san francisco natalia was
living on campus and schwab
and i i did not own a car either so i
had the
doubly fun time of using many modes of
public transit to get to and from
uh where we needed to go um but i will
say it is quite doable um there is
uh options to it's very easy to get to
the caltrain which
usually gets you to just about any major
you know city that i don't know where in
the south bay
your partner might be working but um i
can bet that there's probably a caltrain
spot that gets you
gets you pretty close and then you know
there's several other options
for public transit if you have a car
which
is maybe advisable uh if you are going
to be having a daily uh commute into
work once once things start to lift up
um there's ample parking options um
on campus for for an additional um cost
and uh you can you know drive down
um to and from the south bay or uh if
you need to commute up to
san francisco as well but um you know i
think the obvious
uh downside is that there's just
additional kind of um
you know with living off campus there's
some additional commuting
um to get to campus if you're if you're
living together um so that's just
something else to keep in mind is
um you know do you have multiple cars if
you're living in palo alto one of you
needs to commute to campus and one of
you needs to
um you'll go down to uh the south bay or
something like that so um
yeah just just any consideration there
as well i would say also
um a lot of the people who have partners
off campus but are
who are local um they'll be like a slop
or a whatsapp group where people do ride
shares so
hey i need to ride up to san francisco
who else is going to go visit you know
their partner for the weekend
or even on a weeknight and that's a fun
way to just
if especially if you don't have a car to
carpool with people and it makes it a
lot more efficient
great thanks i thought i saw a question
a little earlier i don't see it now so
i'm guessing somebody may have answered
it in the chat but
uh for the partners on the call who were
navigating
uh job searches here in the bay area
uh can anyone speak to that experience
um just out of curiosity like tori
or eric did you come with jobs already
or did you end up utilizing the career
center resources
as a partner
i mean i i can go first um i did come
with a job and i was not
looking to use any of the cmc or career
resources i think to tori's point
um maybe she made earlier there are so
many events and there's so many
opportunities to kind of network and
kind of expand your
your horizons and get to meet people
which is of course advantageous to the
career of
a partner but um i i did not use any i
guess formal resources um through the
career management center
i did reach out and i'm not going to
explain the
bizarre circumstances that i was going
through but
initially i was looking for a job and
did work with the career center to be
put onto some leads
they they do offer um their support to
partners
my understanding is it's not the same as
the support they offer to students which
is
um very extensive for partners they will
do some things but
i believe not everything um they put me
on to some stanford
connections in the areas that i was
interested in which was obviously a
great help
and i definitely got some interviews um
from
some of those leads which was really
helpful um
someone else put in the chat um you know
can partners work
it depends where you're from make sure
if you're an international you know your
visa situation
what visa you're applying for what your
ability to work is because in my
situation
if i wanted to work in the u.s i had to
have an employer and be sponsored
and have that contract before i could
even get my visa to actually go over to
the us
so be very careful because it can take
i would allow like depending on your
situation you know
up to six months for your for your job
search and visa process
um it took me um you know probably
two to three months to make that happen
um
in terms of getting a new job in the end
i ended up sticking with my current
employer
um who did an inter-company transfer to
um from australia to the us which was
actually the most straightforward way
for me so if you work for a
multinational company
i would recommend exploring that route
um
uh so yeah i did use the cmc there are
resources available
make sure you give a lot of time and do
a lot of research
great thank you i'm going to turn things
over to
the students now to hear your
perspective uh
and again this is speaking from from
just your own personal experience
you know what we tell people as they're
thinking about applying to stanford is
that really every class
is different every class sort of takes
on a personality of its own
uh and in any given year we don't know
how many people may be applying with
partners or families
uh so curious to hear from parker
natalia eric
amanda uh of your class experiences
um can you describe the families and
partners uh kind of
life uh on campus in terms of how active
uh the partners and families were in
your class because
i know sometimes that can shift year to
year some years there seems to be you
know more groups of families than others
so just curious from your own personal
perspectives
some of the things that stand out in
your mind
and amanda feel free to pop yours in
chat if we're worried about you're
coming in clear right now but just in
case
yeah i can i can just share a couple
thoughts real fast um
so i i definitely think that um it might
have been
lacey or someone who mentioned it um and
again having been on both sides
it really is uh around how much you know
you as the
how much partners i think put into um
wanting to invest in the community
wanting to be part of it wanting to to
be active and
um you know i think it's incumbent on
the students to to be welcoming and to
be inviting and
um yeah i think more often than not i
can think of instances where you know
natalia
and i will just kind of add the other
person to an invite or you know bring
them along for for a dinner and i think
that's that's very
well received and i think it it starts
to create that
you know kind of momentum around
building as natalia said those
one-on-one relationships
uh and that's a and i've found some of
the most you know um
i think memorable and engaging
experiences i've had with you know
partners as well as
again on the other side of the table to
be um taking that time to
to reach out um be proactive as a an so
to
try to create those one-on-one
relationships and i think it actually
goes a long way towards
bettering your experience and making you
feel like a larger part of the community
um as you as you go through your time at
the gsb
and i also think beyond social i mean
there's like a million plus events that
as an so you'll
you know become a part of whether it's
you know small form or even larger form
but
from a professional standpoint there's
also a lot of upside so a couple of
examples that come to mind is one
sometimes gsb students can help you
prepare for job interviews i know
some of my classes our classmates helped
eric prepare for his interviews
another example is we had
i can think of three um sos or three
partners from my classes here who
actually started companies
with some of my classmates so
professionally
they were very integrated in terms of
you know the startup community but also
even
the more like traditional career route
um aspects of the gsb
i'm gonna try and get my internet to
hold
um let's just said it's unstable that's
right
gsb partners are awesome
like this is not like a just an so
like tag along like the people that i
have met who are partners are
genuine friends of mine some of whom
i've connected with more closely
than other students in my class um like
a friend of mine who's an
so we go rock climbing together i
haven't met anybody else who has that
same
passion as i do um in a class community
more like surfing or um we have really
interesting
community i'm sorry we have interesting
discussions on things that are outside
of the gym
i got my main point across eso's are
awesome
i love them you're a huge part of the
community and you enrich it
so much so yeah that's all
couldn't have said it any better parker
is there anything else you'd like to add
maybe from the from the family lens
yeah i just was always so impressed with
how my classmates would engage
not just with lacie but with our kids um
and so that was always
just super fun to see that side of
everybody that
maybe you don't always see you know in a
work environment or something like that
or a classroom environment
and i i cannot honestly think of a time
where lacey came along where uh you know
we weren't both
super welcome and um and just you know
part of the community so um yeah i mean
i think it really is it really is great
and i and i
too have made friends with other
partners and
or so's um so yeah i think
not not much else beyond that
thanks everyone i'm going to address a
quick question here but
uh for anyone who's maybe had this
experience feel free to chime in
uh victor is wondering can partners
audit classes
at the gsb so so officially you cannot
audit an entire class but for partners
who may have done this i do believe that
if you have
a student they may be able to request
permission from a faculty member for you
to sit in on a particular class
i know sometimes that is at their
discretion depending on what might be
covered in the classroom but
was anyone ever able to attend a class
or two
as a guest with faculty permission
yeah um i mentioned this early on i'm
sorry
we're going crazy now but um we
i think every single class that was
parker's top favorite or he was
presenting
i was able i don't think i mean
correctly if i'm wrong i don't think you
ever once
asked if i could come and we're told no
i i mean
i didn't try and do you know a bunch of
classes
in the same semester but i would
you know one here so great
thank you um speaking of the the partner
experience i know i'm looking at the
clock and we've got a little bit of time
left but i would love to hear
a little bit more about some of your
personal favorite experiences
at the gsb we talked a little earlier
about how many uh events and social
activities
uh and guest speakers are open to the
the partner
and gsb community broadly so i'm
wondering if any of you have any
favorite memories or experiences that
you got to participate in
yeah i uh good reminder good reminder to
tell you um
yeah i i i'll share just a few things
that quickly come to mind um
first is actually i think ties into
auditing classes a little bit
um there's just such a special group of
lecturers and professors that work at
the gsb
and almost all of them are willing and
open to having dinners or interactions
outside of class
and so natal and i actually had a really
awesome you know like one-on-one
uh i guess double date with uh with the
professor and his wife um
last summer which i think was just a
really special kind of experience um as
an so to meet a professor just
that close and and kind of see and learn
from from him and his wife which was
just a tremendous experience and
i anticipate that happening more second
is definitely traveling
i think there's a lot of opportunities i
think as someone mentioned it's mostly
the student led
you know group trips that you can go on
but those are really really special ways
to really solidify those bonds and to
feel like part of the community
and hopefully you know with that with
some covert restrictions and things like
that that are
loosening you might there might be more
opportunities to do that especially for
for incoming classes
um and the third thing uh which i think
is really valuable is um
i'm sure most of you who are applying to
the gsb have heard of touchy feely
um which is a very prominent course that
a lot of students take
um and then i actually as an so had the
chance to engage in a touchy-feely
weekend retreat
which was a tremendous tremendously
important and impactful
experience and you know having now taken
the full class i can say it really does
match with uh
with what you learn in the course itself
and there's just a lot of ways to i
think
kind of develop yourself emotionally and
you know mentally through
through that type of a program and so i
would encourage you all to to
investigate that
as you uh embark on your journeys
thanks eric uh lacey tori any favorites
for you
mine was definitely the class troops i
mean we had a very um
unusual year as i think um eric alluded
to and that
those were probably the the primary way
that the class really had had the chance
to
um get to know one another um so it was
really awesome to be able to
go skiing and explore some of the
national parks around california
um do yosemite and uh
that was really fun to get to go camping
with some of the class
um i really enjoyed it
i actually did like the traveling also
um we probably didn't do as much
but um the trips are always memorable
and also
um but there's a i can't remember what
it's called anymore c4c what does it
stand for
um anyway okay okay yes
um i just thought the involvement there
was really fun there's just a lot of
great energy because you're thinking
about
something that's bigger than yourself
which is kind of the whole point of
stanford right like this
this whole thing is quickly that was a
great experience for
me personally and for our children
thanks lacey
well keeping an eye on the clock here
i'd love if we can kind of wrap up and
kind of pull this all together if we
think about our audience here today
uh many of the folks on the line are
thinking about applying in the next year
or two
and so if you can all reflect back to a
year two
three or so ago uh when you were in
their shoes and you were thinking about
this big decision to come to business
school either
as the student or as part of a couple
that was pursuing that journey together
what advice might you have for the
students the partners the families out
there
as they're thinking about business
school and they're kind of at the front
the front uh line here of this journey
any pieces of advice or tips or
suggestions that you would make for the
group today as they
as they take the next steps
i'm happy to go so i i do remember
throughout the application process um
feeling kind of constantly intimidated
by people that i met who had attended
the gsp
or you're sort of reading into every
little detail on the admissions website
so it's like okay
i see somebody that did mckinsey and i
see somebody else who's
founded some incredible non-profit i
didn't do either of those things that
seems bad
um and so i think just getting past all
of that
and just really focusing on
you know your own story and your own
goals and
the experience that you'd like to create
for your own mba program and
not trying to not trying to guess um
what like the admissions committee wants
to hear or anything like that and i
think
once i arrived at stanford i was so
blown away by the
incredible diversity on every possible
dimension including diversity of
experience
and there is no traditional background
at stanford there's no
there's no playbook for getting into
stanford so i think just you know for
those of you who are
about to write those essays or take the
gmat or whatever you're going to do just
have some confidence that
there's somebody that's just like you
that got into stanford at some point and
so like you have
like you you like have a shot to get in
um as
much as anybody does so um yeah that's
what i would say about that
thanks parker and thank you amanda for
for weighing in
on chat there uh natalia eric anything
come to mind for either of you today
this is more advice for i guess you know
as you think about your class and your
cost is a big part of your identity
but both you know the partner and the
student should
think about there's so many events and
opportunities
to interact with the class above you and
below you as well i think that's
sometimes an opportunity that can be
missed and so
if you and your partner um kind of plan
to make sure that you know you don't
just invest in the class
that you're a part of but also the other
classes there's a lot
of great like cross-pollination that can
happen there whether it's through social
events or even things like the women's
golf clinic
um there's all of these opportunities
great advice
all right i would love to hear from the
partners thinking about the partner
experience
uh anything you did or in
hindsight wished you could have done in
terms of supporting your
student as they were embarking on this
experience
or to the partners out there anything
you want to give them a heads up on
yeah i'll just i'll throw one out there
which is um
be flexible be adaptable uh and be
willing to ask questions
um i think as as a as a partner
the especially fall quarter when
there is just an inundation a deluge of
new things that are that are going on
that it's really important i think to
establish expectations establish
routines and also recognize that
the gsb can be a really quirky place and
you know there's
there's some sometimes you might be like
why is my
partner prioritizing doing that over
this and i think it's just kind of
leaning into and being slightly flexible
um
as this experience really is you know uh
transformational in so many different
ways um and
both for for a partner and for the
student themselves and so
um yeah i think being adaptable and
flexible and
to ever said it earlier setting
expectations i think is really critical
um i agree with that i also agree um
with what amanda said
in the chat about um working together
um from the beginning including included
from the beginning the whole admissions
process
and i can't everybody's gonna have their
own experience but for us
i i will always talk about the gsb like
it was ours
even though i didn't get a graduate
degree from the stanford
graduate school of business because i
changed my life just as much as parker
changed his
and it it disrupted and interrupted and
it
it transformed us too um and so for
me it was important that i was involved
every step of the way i read
every essay i read every you know
application
and i celebrated the same way when he
got his call um
and so for i think that that was
something that made
it important for us is that we were in
it together from the very beginning
until the end
thank you lacey tori i'll definitely
echo that the only thing i would add is
um depending on sort of where you are
whether you're on campus or whether
you're
like a million miles away um just
try just make sure that you try and get
involved in whatever way it is
like it makes life more fun and
interesting
if you're not just kind of focused on
your own life and your own work
and you you try and get involved in um
in meeting your partners stanford
friends and going along to events and
trips because you'll
get so much more out of the experience
the more that you're involved um
and echo uh eric and laci's input as
well
well thank you all so much i truly
cannot thank you enough for spending
your time with us today
especially for those of you who uh kept
some very odd hours to join us i really
do appreciate it
i just shared my screen for one last
moment here so for those of you
who joined us today thank you we do hope
this has been helpful for you to give
you a better sense of the
partners and families experience here at
stanford's graduate school of business
for those of you who are continuing this
journey and planning to apply
soon i encourage you to check out and
create your own personalized dashboard
as you go through this experience
uh on mystanford.mba and a quick plug
for some upcoming events from our office
we're actually hosting an application
week
at the first week in august so for those
of you who are planning to apply this
year or
just want to do some early prep for the
future our office will be hosting a
number of workshops and sessions the
first week in august
to help you and guide you through that
application process
so while you are hopefully turning to
your partners and
they're helping you uh you know
proofread and edit those essays if
you're also looking for some advice from
us or just some guidance
to help get you over that finish line to
hit submit in september
we hope you'll join us for some of those
sessions so a huge thank you again to
our panel thank you so much it was
lovely to see you all
and thanks to all of you for spending
some time with us today so best wishes
and we look forward to seeing your
application soon
take care everyone